president Trump's nominee to lead
Veterans Affairs faces some unexpected
obstacles this morning senators are
considering postponing tomorrow's
confirmation hearing for Ronnie Jackson
potentially damning allegations emerged
about his time as White House doctor
this morning our longtime contributor
from the Washington Post at O'Keeffe
debuts as a CBS News correspondent
good morning mr. correspondent good
morning John and what have we learned
about these allegations
well the Montana senator Jon Tester
Democrat is investigating allegations
that have been made against Jackson
regarding what we're told quote is a
hostile work environment the so far so
far unproven allegations also suggest
there's been some excessive drinking on
the job and that the doctor has possibly
been prescribing medications dispensing
medications inappropriately these again
so far unproven allegations coming with
bipartisan concern that the doctor may
be in a little over his head while he's
a former battlefield surgeon and
currently oversees a staff of about
seventy at the White House medical
office the Department of Veterans
Affairs employs 350,000 people across
the country has a budget of 185 million
dollars and Democrats and Republicans
have said publicly they worry he may not
be able to manage such a sprawling
department second only in size to the
Pentagon plus there's criticism about
the glowing review he gave of the
president's health at a news conference
back in January and the White House has
had some issues with vetting people
working in the administration what are
we hearing from the White House on this
well they're standing by Jackson at
least at this hour saying in part in a
statement that Admiral Jackson's record
of strong decisive leadership is exactly
what's needed at the VA to ensure our
veterans receive the benefits they
deserve
okay add more to come on this thanks so
much welcome to the team thank you
glad to have you mr. ed